der islam gehört zu deutschland das ist
ein satz von christian wulff der damals
wie heute ein streitthema bleibt nicht
aber für diesen mann andreas lipp will
bürgermeister von kerpen werden und ja
wird es genau damit geht sogar noch
weiter für ihn gehört der muezzin ruf
auch dazu dieser bürgermeisterkandidat
ist mir jetzt zugeschaltet ich freue
mich auf andreas lipp er den er der
islam gehört zu deutschland das finden
sie richtig warum diese menschen ganz
einfach mit uns hier in deutschland
leben dass es dich familie sie ist wie
sie sagten von christian wulff und diese
menschen leben schon seit vielen
generationen bei uns ja auch in
deutschland von daher müssen wir auch
gemeinsam zusammen leben können und
müssen halt eben auch über die themen
von den jeweils anderen gruppen reden
können
das heißt auch der muezzin rufe sei
durch kärnten klingen
darüber soll genau der stadtrat sprechen
und dieses thema ist bereits seit
mehreren monaten für den integrationsrat
in kerpen adressiert der wirt war
spielsystem auf dann wahrscheinlich in
der ersten sitzung nach der
konstituierenden sitzung des rates dann
auch behandelt werden
an mich herangetragen wurde diese bitte
aus den muslimischen gemeinden dass in
der politik darüber gesprochen werden
möge was ich sehr gern getan habe und
das ist jetzt gerade auch aktuellen
punkt wo ich merke dass es eine große
gruppe an rechten menschen gibt die
versuchen genau diese themen klein zu
halten denn seitdem dieses thema durch
die sozialen medien auch heute die
letzten tage hochgespielt worden ist für
billig entsprechenden zwischen von
rechtsradikalen bedroht worden kriege
droh-mails kriege drohanrufe so dass ich
inzwischen auch die polizei einschalten
musste und anzeige erstatten werden
musste und ich inzwischen meine
öffentlichen auftritten noch mit
polizeischutz machen kann dieses thema
bei der spd basis an
da habe ich sehr breite zuspruch also
ich kriege sehr viel unterstützende
anrufe whatsapp nachrichten und der
themen ist es allen nachrichten fast
gleich wir stehen nicht nur hinter dir
wir stehen vor dir und wenn notwendig
stehen wie auch nicht nur nebenher und
wenn notwendig stehen wir auch vor dir
und das stützt mich in meiner ansicht
hier alles richtig gemacht haben denn
wenn wir alle hier gemeinsam leben
wollen müssen wir auch alle gemeinsam
reden und wenn es ein solches thema wie
den mut ihn ruft gibt dann kann man doch
durchaus darüber reden
und am ende wird die politik entscheiden
ob man das zulässt oder nicht zulässt
und wenn ich darüber gesprochen wird so
ist es auch keine integration in solchen
fällen geben glauben sie hält der star
ist das auch ein thema für scholz wäre
dass er mit dem er zur wahl antreten
sollte
es ist ja eine gesetzeslage ob muezzin
rufe erlaubt sein dürfen oder nicht oder
unter welchen auflagen ich glaube nicht
dass das jetzt ein bundespolitisches
thema ist zumal es erfolgen paar tagen
erst einmal dazu gegeben hat und ich
glaube dass wir auf der
bundespolitischen ebene weitaus
wichtigere themen zu besprechen haben
und auch zu entscheiden haben als
religiöse themen und in diesem fall ein
muss
warum sollte denn ihrer ansicht nach dem
guten ruf durch karten klingen und wie
weit wollen sie gehen auch das thema
schwimmunterricht getrennten
schwimmunterricht den nehmen sie sich ja
auch an
also ich sage nicht mit dem letzteren
haben das thema damit schwimmen ist
ironischerweise nicht von den
muslimischen verbänden an mich
herangetragen wurden sondern ich habe
das thema dasselbe mit drei gebracht
weil ich in diversen
seniorenvertretungen darauf angesprochen
worden ob es nicht die möglichkeit gibt
in uns im bett an unserer stadt auch
geschlechter getrennte schwimmen mal
anzubieten dass die frauen hat jemals
zwei stunden ohne männer und ohne blöde
kommentare von männlichen mit schwimmen
dort hat eben mal schwimmen kann
das ist doch nichts verwerfliches im
gegenteil das kennen wir alle auch von
fitness studios wo es ja auch
entsprechend um frauen fitness stunden
gibt wo es eben ohne männer in dem
gleichen fitnessstudio trainiert werden
kann
und ich halte das immer mit leben und
leben lassen solange jeder alles nutzen
kann sich überall wieder finden kann und
wir aber alles noch reden können
dann ist eigentlich für alles gesorgt
weil er sich auf einen bestimmten punkt
immer nur so kaputt zu kaprizieren und
dann in dem aktuellen fall entsprechend
dann auch noch eine tasse petze das
ganze in eine richtung treiben zu wollen
das kann nur der falsche weg sein das
kann nicht gut sein für eine
gesellschaft die zu gut zusammenleben
möchte
wenn blöde sprüche von männern gegenüber
frauen in schwimmbädern in kerpen so wie
sie es sagen jetzt wirklich passieren
ist es dann wirklich der richtige weg
getrennte schwimmstunden anzubieten oder
müsste man dieses problem nicht an einem
an ganz anderen kern packen wir mögen
sie
naja wenn wenn wenn frauen in kerpen
beleidigt werden oder von männern blöd
angeredet werden in einem schwimmbad
meint sie dass es dann wirklich der
richtige weg ist die schwimmstunden zu
zu trennen oder sollte man nicht an
diesem punkt beginnen und sich die frage
stellen warum werden frauen polit
angesprochen woher kommt das und was
können wir dagegen als gesellschaft tun
das muss man natürlich auch tun weil
wenn es das gibt und ich kann das nicht
bestätigen ich bin mir gesagt gefragt
wurden und man hat mir das als beispiel
genannt das ist halt eben wir frauen
angenehmer wäre auch für die senioren
mal ein zwei stunden im schwimmbad ohne
männliche begleitung hat ihm schwimmen
zu können
sicher wenn es dieses problem gibt
müssen wir es gerne backen
nichtsdestotrotz sollte man auch darüber
reden ob man nicht an solche
möglichkeiten des geschlechter
getrennten schwimmens anbieten kann
und das soll ja nicht grundsätzlich so
sagen ja wir reden ja nicht davon dass
jetzt im nächsten auf die männerstimmen
gehen dürfen oder die frauen das zu
getrennten zeiten sondern man muss halt
eben schauen dass du denn dass dieses
ansinnen gibt und es dafür eine mehrheit
gibt wie man das technisch umsetzen kann
und wenn es mehrheiten dafür gibt wir
leben in einer demokratie und wirst du
etwas beschlossen und wenn es dafür
keine mehrheiten gibt und was nicht
beschlossen sie haben eingangs in
unserem gespräch davon gesprochen dass
sie bedroht werden dass sie mit
polizeischutz auftreten
ja inwiefern beeinflusst sie das was
macht das mit ihnen was löst das in
ihnen aus bestärkt dass sie in ihrem
thema oder bereitet ihnen das auch große
sorge also zunächst einmal ist man
natürlich geschockt weil damit rechnet
man nicht erst recht nicht mit so einer
heftigkeit und ich war zwar immer
bewusst dass wir nicht irgendwann in der
öffentlichkeit stehe als politiker das
irgendwann natürlich dass in eine gruppe
gibt die den ich nicht gut gefallen aber
nach dem ersten schreck bin ich da
ziemlich rangegangen und
sondern sage mir jetzt selber ja jetzt
erst recht denn die bedrohungen und die
dort kommen sind ganz klar aus der
rechten ecke
und da sage ich die spd ist nun mal ein
bollwerk gegen rechts gewesen und jetzt
erst recht keinen millimeter schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergisst
nichts abonnieren